bei christian b gibt es heute auch eine
andere nachricht denn laut seiner
anwälte hatte erneut einen antrag auf
frühzeitige haftentlassung gestellt was
genau das bedeutet möchte ich nun
besprechen mit doktor alexander stevens
erste rechtsanwalt für strafrecht guten
abend herr dr
christian b hatte bereits einmal solch
einen antrag gestellt ihnen dann
zurückgezogen und jetzt erneut gestellt
warum macht man das was ist das für eine
taktik weil er es gab einen streit wer
überhaupt zuständig ist
christian beeck modernen braunschweig
inhaftiert zunächst zunächst war das
nämlich eine bewährungsstrafe gewesen
die wurde widerrufen
und dann ist er in kiel gelandet und
dann hatte er sich fälschlicherweise
vermutlich in braunschweig an den antrag
auf vorzeitige entlassung gestellt hat
dann festgestellt naja braunschweig hat
mich aber zumindest das landgericht
braunschweig habe mich wegen
vergewaltigung verurteilt ist vielleicht
nicht ganz gut wenn das landgericht
braunschweig dann über eine vorzeitige
haftentlassung entscheidet und hat sich
dann am kiel gewarnt also dem bezirk dem
landgericht in dem bezirk seien seine
haftanstalt ist und da hat der bgh
zunächst ein machtwort gesprochen und
gesagt nein braunschweig ist zuständig
weil die viel sagt er sind die die
kennen sich mit dem fall aus sie können
das viel besser entscheiden ob man
christian b jetzt wirklich entlassen
soll
daraufhin hat er den antrag
zurückgenommen weil sie sich gesagt hat
okay braunschweig werde ich
wahrscheinlich keinen blumentopf
gewinnen hat den antrag zurückgenommen
und jetzt erneut gestellt und jetzt wäre
tatsächlich kiel zuständig denn wenn das
durchgeht
wie aussichtsreich ist solch ein antrag
sprich wie groß ist die chance
tatsächlich dass christian bär jetzt
frühzeitig aus der haft entlassen wird
und auf freien fuß kommt also ich würde
die chance 15 15 grundsätzlich hat man
nämlich tatsächlich die möglichkeit wenn
man zwei drittel seiner strafe
abgesessen hat wieder auf freien fuß zu
kommen
jetzt ist es natürlich so dass christian
beeck ein unbekannter ist und jetzt auch
eine weitere
strafe gegen ihn herunter schuldig
gesprochen
allerdings diese strafe noch nicht
vollstreckt wird weil er dagegen in
revision gegangen ist das heißt faktisch
gilt er weiterhin als unschuldig nur ob
er so viele freunde bei einem gericht
hat das jetzt über seine vorzeitige
haftentlassung entscheiden soll
das wage ich zu bezweifeln können auch
die ermittlungen im fall maddie jetzt
dazu beitragen dass er vielleicht nicht
frühzeitig entlassen wird
nein tatsächlich hat das eine mit dem
anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun auch im
fall maddie gilt er ja als unschuldig
bis man ihnen das gegenteil beweist und
vor allem dass er verurteilt wurde und
auch da kann er dann selbst wenn er
verurteilt würde auch nochmal
rechtsmittel einlegen das ganze würde
sich ewig ziehen und so lange gilt man
in deutschland als unschuldig das heißt
dass ein hat überhaupt nichts mit dem
anderen zu tun